welcome to this video the highlights
video for rotate the first round of the
second turn this tournament and this
round sees some the game between the two
leading players were both on plus 22
wins and the island has two wins and no
loss while aronia has three wins and
losses lost against are not of course
first round so yeah let's have a look at
the game first Aronian against island
yeah we have a reti opening and now
Aronian comes up with an entirely new
idea queen bee three and almost unknown
muth and yes Kramnik set in this press
conference yeah I have looked at this
move but it's so silly that I couldn't
even bring myself to be played in a
rapid game yeah I wouldn't go so far
that it's not totally silly but it
serves mainly one purpose to to get a
game without I'm getting into a deeper
theoretical better like in the sloth
defends on any kind of um yeah well
explored opening um yeah it covers upon
another's playing deform ambitious move
gaining space in the center and this
basically involves the pawn sacrifice is
after e3 you don't want to take and give
white this huge center you played c5 and
after that are only in quickly shot at
queen bee five yeah simply winning this
bond okay Black is gaining lots of
development on the Queen yeah and we see
that after eight moves white has played
five moves with the screen so um yeah
throw out your textbooks no don't move
the Queen in the opening yawa the number
two player and the former world champion
I high in a game where the number two
players moving all the time the Queen
yeah it's um obviously risky what
Aronian is
he is not developing and giving black
quite nice play in the center here on
our plate Bishop c5 in fact here the
move Knight f6 was maybe the more
interesting try to set white some
problems one point is that Bishop b2 is
not good due to d3 young going for this
forks and if white is playing the
catcher you have a four and this leads
to very sharp play obviously as right
cannot move the night this is very bad
evil yeah d5 as the move takes and takes
and in this position the move Bishop c5
is interesting with really crazy
complications now one one idea is some
that if white is greedy now and takes
there is Sir Queenie seven and this is
probably just winning for black yes yeah
what is this you don't even need to
analyze and white must play this smooth
very crazy stuff after which black can
capture check on ta is an excellent
shape threatening Bishop e7 winning the
queen or winning the Queen after this
really crazy stuff Knight f6 I believe
was was the more interesting really I
mean aronian is not lost or anything but
he needs to defend very precisely after
that after Bishop c5 which was island
smooth aronian managed to block the
center and check complete his
development slowly 92 and a 5 / black so
black is upon down aunt is a
compensation is not so apparent but it
is there and it's mainly focused or it's
mainly due to one thing this is this
idea night coming to c5 and possibly
even F
while white is really in somewhat of a
passive position he retreated the Queen
another Queenie's you know unplayed
bishop d6 yeah he didn't want to play
play this so first retreated and stood
with the idea to play night to see five
yeah 91 by aronia possibly intending
Bishop g4 and now 95 yeah and here it is
some really not so easy to play white
something like this for example like
will play a four and just after let's
say here you really are oppressed with
white what are you doing I mean you're
very very passive and blackest maybe
even coming with their five it's not not
much fun to play aronian played this
move and I'll not went back to a 6
threatening efore a 4 and to return
which Aronian answered with 92 and well
and wants to have this a 4th fret so he
plays 95 and you get the hunch yes it's
really like that they repeat it and make
the draw in this position yeah allowed
boo is coming from the audience okay
yeah I understand that I also would have
liked to have a big battle but it's a
it's quite understandable really in this
position aronian has made an opening
experiment that in a way failed because
he has a very passive position on the
other hand it's not like wishes just
winning or has a clear-cut way to an
advantage on but he is comfortable but
he's also very comfortable with the draw
in the tournament situation as you
always need to keep in mind that this
draw means that the mini match that he
has with Aronian is worn by anat he won
the first game now a draw here so shove
the tournament with the tournament end
right now then Anand is the Challenger
because if he's on the same score with
Aronian
then the direct match decides so so on
and a draw in this game was perfectly
acceptable he would certainly have
continued if you thought he'd had a
clear advantage that's that's obvious
but it's not like that it's just a
comfortable position but ok your porn
down and you know and yeah I could have
roro niall played on yeah I doubt it
really it's a it's not very comfortable
to play on the computer is suggesting
really we are looking stuff like a 42
block against this but then you really
have completely destroyed your queen
side extra porn and well at five is just
coming at some point after preparation
or even immediately hard to tell I mean
it's it's just not much fun to play and
you also need to be aware of aronian
would lose the game would have lost the
game um he's in terrible a terrible
position 1 1 point behind are not and
the worst tie-break terrible so it's a
bit of a played safe decision very
understandable it keeps both players
chances intact okay let's go to the next
game top off Mammadyarov both are lost
the round before so topalov lost in a
drastic fashion in mamedyarov spot this
winning position against chronic Phobos
certainly not in the best of moods yeah
we have a night off to Palo playing the
open Sicilian and he placed the topical
h3 line which prepares an early g4
madiha Grove case goes for a sideline he
plays with g6 or this is fairly normal
looking and long castle so a sharp game
we have opposite opposite sides castle
and attacks in the center and on the
king yeah Mammadyarov goes for a quick
play with 94 and Nepal off must really
stop that he played to be three which is
on the other hand also weakening the
King position a bit but it was necessary
so nothing else come in here and the
night retreated to cover this now loose
night b5 and 95 very normal moves that
are typical for this type of position
white wants to use this outpost and now
establish a pawn on d5 which severely
limits the night on a 5 this night is a
key piece of course it is offside cannot
go here cannot go here and now I can go
to be seven but who wants to go to be 70
so it's why better here it looks like
white is comfortable but Normandy off
has thought of account apply and this is
very interesting play d6 now rook f2
yeah this was probably designed to cover
the sensitivity to square more of a
defensive set up and yeah here
Mammadyarov plate oops didn't expect
that but it's in fact a very good move
he just solves the problem of the night
by sacrificing it yeah and okay white
needs to take no I know are you here and
here it's it's very very concrete
blackest threatening to play c3 and then
just made white and this is also
happening if white wooden place III this
is just winning from black this attack
it seems that the absolute best defense
is one to power off plate he played
Bishop d4 and now c3 Bellamy dr aafia
and it turns out that black will get a
piece back white cannot keep it I cannot
do some something like that is again
lost this is the absolute best move yeah
and now we see that with this sequence
he's getting the porn back Mammadyarov
and retains an active position with the
rook a both looks actually this is also
ready to enter and after a couple of
more moves
we came to a rogue and game which was
agreed drawn him yeah a game which had
one really exciting moment when this
night sacrifice was coming but it seems
that it's one of those cases where both
sides simply play correctly and we end
in a draw almost by force after this the
sharp continuation with 94 yeah a good
game by both players it's it does not
help them really both would desperately
need a win to at least um come near
having a chance but yeah a draw is not
helping both of them but objectively
speaking a very correct and and fine
game um okay Cromley gun draken next
yeah we got the chobani ankles laughs
this is what and draken has prepared for
the tournament it seems he had played an
a6 laughs earlier and chronic played g3
which is no surprise because he had to
play this before and the fun thing is
that and raking now took 20 minutes to
play b5 on Lou 5 this is quite quite
funny I mean he's not really thinking
about this over the board isn't he he
could really expect you three I mean if
you would give me the task to prepare
against Kramnik and I would need to
guess what what move is coming it going
to play yeah it's clear that you will
play a four or yeah since let's do this
play a four or g3 as this is just his
repertoire so g3 couldn't really come as
a surprise okay but dragon took took at
some time and you found an interesting
set up with this early 90 for this cost
some time as we as we see white is
better developed and after Bishop a3
which is a think a strong idea
he's under some pressure now you cannot
really good play six because yeah this
just takes two to two too much time
white will get a quick initiative
probably also opening the sea far this
is why you went with g6 fianchetto in
the bishop no but white is just quicker
on the sea farm and what after a couple
of more moves really get some dangerous
play on the C file it looks really
threatening but maybe it is a case where
blacks position is just solid enough to
to keep it in in about on about equal
terms he played Queen f6 which is the
strong with an interesting with
attacking two pawns and chrome Nick
already didn't have much of a choice he
needed to sacrifice one of them and this
is what he did he gave her way of three
for an obvious compensation we see that
yet after all this temple gaining moves
he has many active pieces and played the
rook here he's threatening made at the
moment active bishop this rook may swing
over the only has one stupid looking
piece of this is a bishop but I think
Andre can plays a very good defensive
play deaf six f5 also possible f6 seems
okay there should be seven and now Queen
to g5 yeah here maybe this this wasn't
the absolute best move I I don't know um
the computer wants to go H wife and says
it's a compensation very complicated
position right obviously has a very good
compensation for the porn but it's
really hard to tell if it is more than
enough for then then were the pawn this
was played and now Queen d2 the only
move because white has threatened f4 and
exactly here I think chronic is playing
a move that is
it's basically um yeah conceding draw
him at the end it's almost by force
leading to a drawn position he could
have also played Queen III here and this
is a really good suggestion by the
computer black it really has not much of
a choice he needs to basically exchange
now and here we get to a position where
of course they are Queens traded but why
it has a very serious initiative for the
pawn and I believe he has very good
chances to play this position for win
simply by slowly improving the position
you don't need to do anything drastic
here one possible idea could be to
improve this bishop may be here and at
the right moment break open the Queen
side here I think white has serious
chances of increasing the initiative
even more and maybe go for a win later
um what he played is g5 and this does
not really lead to anything I'm dragging
took that I'd even took the second porn
yeah Kramnik obviously thought that he
has a very good initiative even for the
two points that's true he has some plain
but it's probably only good enough for a
draw a couple of moves later it it to
turn out that white here also now being
forced to do something concrete there's
nothing better to take here until they
agree to draw white can check get the
spawn back and play rook c8 now
something like that is just check just
completely dead and yeah a drop was
agreed a couple of moves earlier in this
position this position in fact they
agreed to a draw yeah very I think
relatively correct game and Drake and
played a very good defense really being
under pressure right from the opening
with the somewhat strange our time
management and preparation but Kramnik
maybe he could have done this
when I mentioned this Queen III move to
to to sustain the initiative but very
very tough all those decisions while g5
wasn't enough to really em to really do
anything and I guess the draw is a quite
fair is not all right so next game and
last game for this holiday is Villa
kayaking um yes realize on fifty percent
before this game kayaking on minus two
so is basically almost out of it but
surely it certainly wants to win a game
smitha is playing the Kings Indian
attack why are the night f3 move order
the surprise but his varying his opening
she does not want to play you for all
the time especially against people who
play the Berlin and kayaking is one of
those guys okay c5 and here sweetie uh
comes up with an interesting idea efore
a new idea really this move only has
been played once in my database and it's
an interesting pawn sacrifice that kayak
in Nome does not take um yeah if you
want some more info about the opening
stage of this game I suggest you go to
the single video because I explain some
things about the quinceanera tech and
this the merits of this move water that
it cannot repeat here due to time
constraints but just to switch to the
individual game with you I interested in
this opening yeah we got to this
position interesting was c4 and kayaking
play deform that has a slightly dodgy
reputation but he follows it up with an
interesting concept he plays King a jade
and now f5 which is very interesting
because white cannot really take here
and especially not here due to 95 like
winds and if what cannot take if you
take here and play a nothing move black
will play if I've with a good center
yeah so you cannot take so many black
has managed to put pawn on f5 which
controls those two crucial squares yes
we replace 95 inch black took and now
queen c7 an important move that puts
pressure on d5 and prevents the capture
here because you can recapture with the
Queen yes Villa went for porn sec was g6
and to get the night into an attacking
position here on the King side but
kayaking is playing a good defense one
night to f8 one night here to possibly
exchange later yeah and swollen plays it
very directly placing the bishop on d5
like blocks it and after this put some
pressure on d5 I think in this position
I'm siviglia should have taken with the
night on e six after 96 he can take on
g6 and I think this should end in a draw
relief it's almost the first draw after
this sequence black has no way to play
for we neared as bishop age six and
other moves but ok white can also not
win this is in fact gin worse would like
yeah he decided to take here but this
somehow led to an end game where he was
just a pawn down at the moment and after
some moves we went to this structure and
of course here only black can can be
somewhat better okay it's a double poem
but it's still upon and yeah black is
somewhat easier or quicker and attacking
possible weaknesses on the queenside
there's also that idea to play b5 at the
right moment which in fact you know
kayaking he had prepared with b5 and yes
wiggler played Bishop g5 en on Lou 40
last move for the time control which
kayaking responded with the
f-for very good pawn sacrifice to get
something going pressure on f3 yeah we
can look at the end game a bit later
that was some it was difficult to defend
for our force villa um I actually
thought that around here here a three
with the idea before was a good defense
but okay you need to check the the
longer video for the details on that at
the end we got to a position chant got
some trades even got to even got the
depot yeah we got to position we're here
black has there was this pawn which not
look look so important but he's got this
advanced G porn and it's a it's really a
tricky to defend I think he should have
played rookie one here was still
withdrawing chances ruki aight i think
is is losing especially in connection
with the plan that he that he is playing
check but it was said was tricky to her
to see ya here we come to the yeah to
the final point of the game really work
I Akeno invested 16 minutes he certainly
evaluated the Zen game which I believe
is a draw and at the end he played rook
takes d4 simply sacrificing the exchange
follow it up with b6 saving the porn for
the moment and it turns out that this
position is really a completely forced
wind for black because the G porn is
unstoppable and with the most precise
moves that also spilled are found we
come to a race situation at the end
this is absolute best play where the
second Jeep on you had a double pole on
g7 at the end is the decisive factor
like promotes white promotes chat but
black is the first to check and this is
in fact decisive you go to the B file
you lose the Queen and if you go here
check yeah you can lose the Queen as
well something like that check check
uses the queen or you can also go here
check check which leaves the city so
very nice calculation effort by kayaking
with this capture yeah a good fighting
game with kayaking scoring his first
winner of the tournament after really
having a tough first seven rounds yeah
so um what is the standing after the
round um you can yeah you can look it up
of course on the official website but on
any chess website but I can briefly sum
up that aronian a talent are leading
with plus to get two more wins than
losses this plus two as easy to easy to
compare to the other players chronicon
plus one that's the only person of the
of the two and then we got a huge gap
because no one is on fifty percent we
have whose let's let me let me think of
it are they are all on minus one right
under aching this on minus one swidler
1-1 kayaking on minus 12 part of yeah
they're all on minus 1 this is funny we
have really yeah we have five players
they are all on minus one I was just
don't have it in front of me I'm just
calculating in my head so we have all
players or five players are 1-1 and so
one game below fifty percent while
Kramnik is on plus a 1 and are you
aronia and honored
one plus two so it's basically a
three-man race now it's very unlikely
that one of the guys with the minus
score at the moment would actually start
a serious a wind snow and very unlikely
really so aronia are nadal Kramnik
probably will make it which is also yeah
in the case of chronic and huronian
pre-tournament favourites are not this
certainly a surprise but he's playing
excellently well in this tournament so
we cannot really am argue with that that
he's on top of the standings alright
thanks for watching and make sure to
watch the single game videos if you want
really detailed analysis of the games
thanks for watching